okay so tuck friendly bathing suits I
found the tuck bathing suits the tuck
friendly bathing suits so if you need a
women's bathing suit and you have a
little extra meat down there that you
gotta hide you have one option that is
the only bathing suit that I found in
the entire store and it's in the pride
section it's not in the kids section
women's section boys section baby
section it is in the pride section it
was the only one I could find if you
have as she says a little extra meat
down there but they aren't in the kids
section she hasten's dad they're in the
pride section it's just the pride
section that they've set up right in the
front of the store